عائشه تخرج من رحم الركام نايف صحيح
ونذكر مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام العربيه
كانت ترصد معكم لحظه بلحظه محاولات قاده
طفله عائشه الان واخراجها من تحت كومه
الركام
قطع الاتصال ان كنت الان انا اسمعك جيدا
الان يثبتون الان الان نايف
الان نايف بسرعه بسرعه
الان نايف نايف ان كنت تسمعني ان كنت
تسمعني معك جيدا ان كنت تسمعني
طيب
تسمعني بشكل جيد الان يعني
اكتب
نعم عائشه على اكتف المسعفين باتجاه
الاسعاف عائشه عائشه يا نايف عائشه تخرج
من رحم الركام عائشه تعود للحياء عائشه
تخرج من فم الموت نايف عائشه بعد ولاده
قيصريه بعد ولاده عسيره عائشه الان الى
الاسعاف الان تصل الاسعاف نايف
وتحمل الان بالاسعاف تحمل بالاسعاف الان
لحظه فرح لحظات فرح كما تستمع كما تستمع
الكل هنا في حاله فرح الكل هنا في حاله
فرح عائشه الان في الاسعاف نايف عائشه
تتجه الان الى المستشفى وتنضم لشقيقاتها
تنضم لشقيقاتها فاطمه وخديجه نحو ثلاث
ساعات مضنيه نايف نحو ثلاث ساعات مضنيه
ومتعبه على الجميع على اخوالها وعلى جدي
غسان تابعناها وعلى المنق